[Music]
welcome to Tech news briefing it's
Thursday May 11th I'm Zoe Thomas for The
Wall Street Journal
Wednesday was Google's IO developer
conference and this year all eyes were
on how the company's products would
include new features using generative
artificial intelligence and Google
didn't disappoint it announced it's
making its AI chat bot Bard widely
available to English speakers with plans
to roll it out in 40 languages including
Japanese and Korean soon but that wasn't
all it's also rolling out AI search
here's Google CEO Sundar pichai we've
been applying AI to make our products
radically more helpful for a while
with generative AI we are taking the
next step
with the bold and responsible approach
we are reimagining all our core products
including search
Google's AI search won't be rolled out
immediately if you're interested you'll
have to join a waitlist I spoke with our
reporter miles Krupa who was at Google I
O about these developments and what they
mean for the company miles did you get a
chance to test out Google's new
generative search experience I did get a
chance to test out the search features
on Tuesday before the conference and
they felt to me like Google really
trying to integrate this stuff into the
existing experience rather than create a
whole separate experience they're trying
to do it in a way that feels natural to
search including things like links
fairly prominently although maybe not as
prominently as some would hope and
intriguingly it still clearly had some
issues when I was testing it we asked it
who is winning the Russia Ukraine war
and it gave the answer that Ukraine was
winning to which a Google search
executive said it should not have given
that answer at all how does Google plan
to deal with concerns about the AI
search potentially generating incorrect
results
so what Google said is they took the
approach that they basically wanted to
make sure all the answers the AI
generates could be corroborated by links
on the internet so whenever you see a
response it'll have you know at least
three probably links to the right that
generally back up the information given
in the response it also said that it did
some magic with its search index and
Incorporated a bunch of different work
it's been doing on factuality as it
rolls out things like featured Snippets
so it's a previous feature that gives
you sort of a one true answer to a bunch
of different questions so their answer
is basically it was good enough
it's still not perfect and I think we'll
have to see given the way they're
rolling this out whether the early
testers find it decreases or increases
their trust in the answers they provides
so where does advertising fit into all
of this because that's a big money maker
for Google personally when I was asking
it questions on Tuesday I wasn't seeing
a lot of ads but you know Google so far
is saying that there will clearly be
places for advertisements in this new
feature I think there's potential for
new kinds of innovation in the way ads
are delivered For Better or Worse within
the AI generated responses did
announce plans to incorporate a
products yes it's fair to say that
basically every Google product at this
point will have some form of AI in it
the other big announcement was they
rolled out their big new artificial
intelligence model called palm2 and they
said that this would be used across 25
plus products that they're announcing so
that's everything from things like
workspace Gmail Google docs to Android
things that can work on your mobile
phone to clearly search and bard
miles it's felt a bit like Google has
been on the back foot when it comes to
announcing and releasing generative AI
tools especially as compared to its
rival Microsoft with these new releases
where does Google stand now Google on
Wednesday clearly wanted to show the
world that they are still the leader I
think they would say the leader in
artificial intelligence research and
that they're also speeding up the
process of putting this stuff into
products they really threw a lot at the
wall and we'll have to watch the
reaction over the next few weeks the
biggest test will really be how users
respond to these new search features
because they are
quite different from what Google search
normally is the sort of 10 Blue Links
the web addresses that are listed when
you type in something to the search box
while still feeling integrated to the
Google experience so I don't know it
could go either way I think Google is
trying to sort of regain the front foot
after I O all right that's our Google
reporter miles Krupa coming to us from
Google I O thanks miles thanks Zoe
[Music]
now ai wasn't the only new thing Google
showed off at IO it also unveiled a new
tablet and new phones with the Highlight
being its new pixel fold it's Google's
first foray into flexible displays
here's Rick alster low the company's
senior vice president of devices and
services it's the only foldable
engineered by Google to adapt to how you
want to use it with a familiar front
display that works great when it's
folded
and when it's unfolded it's our thinnest
phone yet and the thinnest foldable on
the market with me to discuss this
announcement is our personal Tech
columnist Nicole Nguyen Nicole can you
start by describing the pixel fold to us
the pixel fold looks like a normal phone
from the outside but it has a hinge and
you can open it like a book to reveal a
larger screen so it goes from normal
phone to mini tablet it's a small thing
that can turn into a big thing Okay
Google's competitor Samsung already
makes a foldable phone how is Google's
different Google's is different because
it runs a cleaner version of Android so
it's more similar to a stock version of
Android Samsung's phones typically have
a skin over the operating system and
you'll usually see Samsung apps as
default apps but on Pixel phones Google
apps are the default apps and I think
that's probably the biggest difference
another big difference is the pixel fold
is squatter so it feels more like a
normal phone when you hold it closed
Samsung's Galaxy Z fold is really long
and skinny and so it can feel cramped
when you're typing on it and also the
two screens when folded on the pixel
fold they lie flat the Samsung Galaxy Z
fold has this weird Quirk that leaves a
gap where the hinge is so these are
really small details the biggest
difference is really how android looks
on the phones what is it like
interacting with the software on this
foldable device so it has some typical
Google AI powered Wizardry one standout
feature is called live translate and if
you expand the phone and you point it at
the person that you're conversing with
face to face it'll show the other person
what you are saying in their preferred
language and on the other screen on the
wide screen you'll see what they're
saying in your language and you can also
take high resolution selfies with the
main camera on the back it'll show you a
preview on that front screen if you have
it open apart from some of those
software features are there any pixel
specific features that are going to
attract people who are made
fence about a foldable phone Google did
a lot of work to optimize its Android
apps for the pixel fold screen so that
includes YouTube Gmail and neat those
apps will eventually roll out to other
foldable phones most notably Samsung's
but you'll probably see them on the
pixel first and live translate will be
exclusive to the pixel at launch
that's usually such a draw for people
looking to buy new phones you know for
the folds price I was disappointed that
this camera system didn't get a bigger
upgrade the specs are pretty similar to
the less expensive pixels and what is
the price for the pixel fold it's 17.99
1800 which is the same price as
Samsung's Galaxy Z fold 4 and that's
because screens are a very costly
component of smartphones and this thing
has tripled the screen real estate of a
normal smartphone so if people do want
to spend nearly eighteen hundred dollars
on this phone when and where will they
be able to get it Google is accepting
pre-orders for the fold now but it won't
ship until June I will say that if
you're thinking about getting your first
foldable you may want to hold out until
August when Samsung will probably
release its next Generation fold the
for anybody
side to get into this space the
smartphone market is a little weird
right now where the market is shrinking
overall but Ultra Premium phones are
still selling people tend to buy the
higher end stuff mostly iPhone flagships
and Samsung flagships and Google's most
expensive phone before the pixel fold
was 8.99 and so I think that they are
signaling to the smartphone market that
they too can make a high-end premium
phone and are hoping to attract those
customers alright that's our personal
Tech columnist Nicole Nguyen thanks for
joining us thanks Zoe and that's it for
today's Tech news briefing for more Tech
stories head over to our website wsj.com
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal thanks for listening
foreign